un
Sono nastro che decidono il passo della luna
dice che dico 6 fedele alla favola per chamo
il nastro che li lega non è però dentro
mari e guardia scrofa o pacha fossa
quando pensava al soldato quando I
contano e mentono senza un vestito milione
ti sei divertito completamente ora
sorridi ancora che anche se è tardi
addormentato sono io quando il sole è chi
da qualche parte Android Android
trova già il tuono quando vanno a leggere e
il suo corpo senza muoversi con me mi costa no
So di essere stupito con te di cui sarò
cura e maestro di seminare il testo
del mondo e solo dal tuo riccio tu
stampiamo forni da una nuova tenuta os
Lascerò andare la cecità del karaoke
guantanamera Sparo a un re che
ispira, vado a vedere Tico e
i trailer mi abbracciano su cauzione
nonostante tutto ce l'ha una cipote
il modulo mentale dove porterò
Lo guardi, è solo un gocho, vuoi un mango
condivido tipico che una colpa oggi lo dico
finito quando piccolo essere tessuto come me
cugino costa nota che ama il centro
sociale la tomba che ma incantevole
piccione a terra sparato di mangiarlo
non gli importa che ci siano sempre canzoni
qual è l'anno non mi interessa se scrivono
colonne ritenute più pesanti t
[Musica]
scrivilo martedì olé non da a
iphone se appare solo così tanto prima
cameron e anche se questo non varrà la pena
rigore e agosto in più e chela devi essere a
sii coraggioso sotto voce difficile sostenuto
quello sporco se sono sporchi di notte visitano
signorina incanta il futuro no non ho
fatto un deposito ho fallito canterò
futuro non noi divisione e seguito
Sono con me, lui mi vede, i churros no
divisione a denti con cui mentire
o no non ti calpesto ponte nascita e io
Ti amo ora il desiderio mi divora e non
posso perderti
Noteranno fare amicizia da quando è stato rilasciato
Le mani di fama stanno prendendo il sopravvento, non lo so
stare insieme andare via Sento che arriva lo splendore
lungo i confini solo per te
montano vanno via
alzati e la scorta lo dice dal
canzone nuova un bicchiere e buone condizioni